there are lots of technologies and
communication that go into building a
smart city join us in historic downtown
Austin Texas as we talk to soft-serve
about using the cloud to make smarter
and safer cities so what is a smart city
that's the question of the year I think
so for years we had the notion of this
is the year of mobile and it feels like
now it's this is the year of the smart
city for the last couple of years and it
means something different to everybody I
like to think of them more in terms of
intelligent environments as opposed to
smart cities because for one city of
becoming smart might mean adding lights
that can get brighter or dimmer as
lighting outside changes it could be
having autonomous vehicles it could be
having technologies and sensors put in
place to help people with disabilities
really what I think it is it's an
environment that interacts with the
people that are inside of that
environment and that's why I tend to
drift more toward intelligent
environment where that can be a vehicle
it could be a campus it could be a
building it could be this space that we
have right now if we can be in two
places at the same time physically and
virtually then I think that's a smart
environment have there been any examples
that you can talk about of cities kind
of creating intelligent environments
sure so in the Carolinas Alliance for
innovation out of Greenville South
Carolina
we've got more into the connected
citizen in the smart city environment
and first my last mild transportation
solace and what that is is what happens
when you have five or six different
connected and/or autonomous vehicles all
different systems needing to speak to
each other to the environment and
traffic control needs to be built and
what we were able to do was create a
multimodal transportation let's call it
viewpoint single pane of glass control
tower type of thing where we're able to
see not only where are the vehicles but
what's the most efficient mode of
transportation from a cost standpoint
for the connected citizen to get from
point A to point B and also what's the
most efficient routing for emergency
services vehicles and what have you
essentially we're starting to solve the
big problem that the public sector has
with digital technologies which is
interoperable
so how does one system talk to another
how do they bi-directionally inform each
other when we've been able to do all of
that in GCP and a lot of that is based
on like you just mentioned getting a lot
of data being able to collect it what
does all that technology look like
especially when it comes to Google cloud
when you have just massive amounts of
data coming in and and really new
sources of data that maybe you hadn't
contemplated before it creates piles and
piles and piles of code to go through
and and data files to go through and the
simple fact is is that what used to take
years to do can now be done in minutes
with bigquery so a great example of what
this might look like is collecting from
a whole bunch of sensors which is
largely IOT but like you said that could
be a tire that could be cars that could
be traffic lights that could be anything
collecting all that data transforming it
and making those data decisions
especially the legal ones about who owns
which data who gets visibility into it
making sure it all kind of can play
nicely together by aggregating it and
then ultimately doing analysis on it
yeah I think so and really I think the
the key term here is enablement
right or even empowerment it's the idea
that technology took off at some point
and the government was focused on other
things and now technology that whole
internet thing yeah it's not a thing
it's here it's not going away and so now
the government's in a position where
they say well how do we manage it how do
we tap into it and I think what's
happening is Pandora's box has been
opened and saying okay well now it's
open wow we didn't know all of this was
here and as they implement solutions
like smart lighting like smart cars and
the connected citizen becomes more and
more pervasive well now what do we do
with all this how do we manage it and
then as they drill into it they find out
but this is almost bottomless and we
have to have something that scales
long-term now there's a platform that
soft-serve offers that kind of looks at
all of these aspects can you tell us a
little more about that so we call it the
intelligent Municipality platform and
essentially what that is it's a data
store built on GCP that allows for
collection from myriad points of data
export and connections to any
destination so that we can enable the
public-private partnership to work
together and create digital eCos
and that sits on top of this so we start
out with the basics of where is the data
coming from how many different systems
do we have how do we put them in play to
work with each other and then from there
we now start to say ok what are the
benefits
well what if we can distill things like
amber and silver alerts and get them to
the city corner as opposed to the entire
zip code when a message goes out so
that's a public service benefit ok it
sounds like a lot of this wouldn't have
been possible without some of the
advancements in the cloud especially
recently I think it's a hundred percent
impossible where would you ever put
enough computing power to make it happen
so both because of scale and because of
the technologies being offered but also
some of the new like you mentioned
earlier about bigquery and being able to
to quickly analyze huge amounts of data
very rapidly all of these things have
kind of enabled people to ask how can I
improve where can I use this data and
how can I analyze it I think so
I also think that the ease of use ease
of access and in a way and I'll use this
term abstractly a bit of standards right
there's a certain understanding of what
the Google cloud platform is use these
tools to do these things oh and you can
have people coming out of school ready
to jump in and adopt this well that
takes a lot of the fear out of it for a
public sector entity and really for
anyone well thanks so much for coming in
Rahn and telling us about how soft Sur
helps enable companies including the
public sector to really understand and
do more with their data sure I
appreciate the opportunity thank you
thanks for joining us and stay tuned for
more customer interviews on stack jab
[Music]
you